Buen día El Congreso de Perú va a paso
lento la posición de algunos
legisladores en especial los agrupados
en derecha es en votar en contra del
proyecto propuesto por la izquierda para
el adelanto de elecciones ellos rechazan
que se incluya la el referéndum para
convocatoria a una asamblea
Constituyente y también existen aquellos
que no están de acuerdo con que se
recorte el mandato congresal porque
señalan que va en contra de la
Constitución peruana así las cosas el
congresista Jaime quito quien lidera en
minoría la propuesta de la izquierda le
ha pedido más tiempo al parlamento y la
sesión se va a reprogramar para las tres
de la tarde hora Lima Bogotá Fuentes del
parlamento me indican que la propuesta
de la izquierda apenas en el mejor de
los casos llegaría a reunir alrededor de
45 hubo votos y no va a ser posible que
se junten los 87 votos que son
necesarios para aprobar el adelanto de
las elecciones para el 2023 Francisco
la reforma constitucional que fue
presentada por la presidenta Dina
boluarte y sobre todo Qué futuro tiene
bien el proyecto presentado por el
gobierno de la presidenta Dina boluarte
Establece que las elecciones se tendrían
que revisar el segundo domingo de
octubre de este año y tanto a la
presidenta boluarte como los
congresistas culminarían su mandato en
diciembre para que todo esto surja la
misma fuente es el Congreso me han
señalado que si es que no se exonera del
trámite regular la iniciativa Tendría
que ir primero a la comisión de
Constitución ser debatida analizada y
aprobada Y si esto es positivo será
trasladada a la comisión permanente
donde también va a tener que realizar el
mismo proceso una vez de Esto será
enviada al pleno del congreso para que
sea debatida y aprobada para muchos lo
que están haciendo los congresistas
sería dilatar todo el proceso porque no
estarían de acuerdo no tendrían la
voluntad por adelantar las elecciones
Mientras tanto el Perú está sumergido en
marchas de protesta y también en los
bloqueos que tiene todos los peruanos en
una situación crítica